[Music]
we have other big news out of Washington
tonight Rex Tillerson he is out as
Secretary of State President Trump now
nominating current CIA director Mike
Pompeo to replace Tillerson and the
president has picked Jena Haspel who was
a seasoned spy master with a track
record of being tough on terror and
terrorists to replace Pompeo now Haspel
would become the first female director
in CIA history if in fact she is
confirmed however tonight there's talk
on Capitol Hill that Democrats may fight
hospitals historic nomination due to her
past involvement running overseas black
sites that were set up following the
9/11 terrorist attacks that killed 3,000
Americans joining us now with more Fox
News chief national correspondent ed
Henry by the way ed will be filling in
for our own Shannon Breen tonight at
11:00 Eastern also with us Fox News
national security strategists former
deputy assistant to the president dr.
Sebastian corker you know ed the amazing
thing about this 3,000 Americans were
killed here 3,000 if you go to Gitmo
there were three people total that were
ever waterboarded in spite with all the
debate we had in the country one of them
was Khalid Sheikh Mohammed which because
of that action yeah it's definitely
tough it led to the courier and that led
to bin Laden and that led to killing bin
Laden without which he would probably
still be alive today we can't have evil
exist in this world without doing
something to counter it and if it means
that terror is called on a battlefield
are forced to answer questions well
sadly that's what you have to do because
you're dealing with evil and so Gina
Haspel was at the center of that during
the Bush administration she spent time
in Turkey Central Asia she was running
the New York office for the CIA and was
the liaison to the FBI in the Obama
years when Osama bin Laden as you
mentioned was killed so this was someone
who yes she was involved in the black
sites the so-called black sites being
where you had enhanced interrogation
techniques critics call it torture
you're right there's already been a
debate and we can expect there will be
an even bigger debate in the days ahead
you have Democrats like Chuck Schumer
Dianne Feinstein already saying they'll
use these confirmation hearings to ask
sharp questions about
behavior of post 9/11 but by the way
there'll be some Republicans like John
McCain already out with tough comments
tonight saying she was involved in
torture they're gonna give her a tough
ride in the confirmation but here's the
bottom line
this is something I've talked to people
in the White House about tonight and
they say they're spoiling for this fight
if Democrats and some Republicans in the
Senate want to try to block President
Trump from nominating the first female
to run the CIA all because she was too
tough on terrorists that is a fight they
will have in a midterm election year
good good luck taking that position but
I guarantee you by the time all said and
done they'll back off that I've known
Mike Pompeo dr. korkor for a lot of
years I like him i he has a tough job he
did a good job as the CIA director yet a
lot of mess to clean up I'm not sure how
far he's gotten in all of that and the
thing I like about Pompeo is you're
always able to have a conversation with
him and he would listen whether you
agree or disagree and I found him you
know in the case of Rex Tillerson I
never talked to the guy once he seemed
never to be available for the media and
he was at odds especially on the Iranian
policy of the president I mean President
Trump never wanted to extend that
Iranian deal once but he was fighting
within his own his own you know just his
own in this particular case State
Department absolutely I have the same
opinion of Mike Pompeo as well not only
is he loyal to the president not only
does he believe in the make America
great again agenda he will go down
fighting to clean the swamp he's done
some very quietly he's done some amazing
things at CIA and I can think of no
better person to clean the real swamp
that is foggy bottom and the State
Department not only does he listen to
other people my personal experience
Michael so reaches out for good counsel
from people who are outside the swamp so
Rex Rex failed at the State Department
he isolated the political appointees
from the front office he didn't return
calls from our ambassadors it was time
for him to go and I can think of very
few people who will be as great in Foggy
Bottom as Mike Pompeo sure what is his
reputation on Capitol Hill at Henry very
strong he was a tea party Republican so
initially came
and was seen as more of a conservative
but reach across the aisle a bit first
in his class at West Point certainly won
the respect of Democrats on the hill
with with his prowess on national
security and somebody that a lot of
people raise their eyebrows this Tea
Party guy gonna be able to run the
bureaucracy at the CIA
by all accounts we haven't heard maybe a
single Democrat really raised questions
about that I think the bigger question
is is going to be too close to the
president and compared to Tillerson and
be more of a yes-man that's going to be
an issue for him because Tillerson as
you say was that odds on all of these
things yes he'll be agreeing to much one
last question for dr. korkor
you know you look at the house Intel
report no evidence 14 months in of Trump
Russia collusion and they want to keep
going and going and going and then you
got a special counsel that's it appears
nothing is related to Trump Russia
collusion that he's even investigating
yeah let's just focus on two things
number one Mike Pompeo will never be a
yes-man that's not a criticism we have
to worry about and secondly they're just
insane Shawn listen to what the river
the news I did an interview earlier
today where they're talking about Rex
Tillerson was fired because he said
something negative about Putin yesterday
I was told by a cabinet member Shawn in
December that the plan is to have Mike
Pompeo replace Rex Tillerson at the
State Department that's three months ago
that's reality violator in the news well
said alright guys good to see you